David Boder: [In English] For some reason, the first few words on this spool are missing. This is Spool 9-20. In other words, it is a reproduction of the original Spool number 20. Boder.
David Boder: . . . a young married woman, she understands a bit English, German, and Yiddish, but she prefers for fluency to speak Polish. Eh...[unintelligible] eh, Mrs. Neufeld...
David Boder: [In Russian] Расскажите мне, откуда вы и [неразборчиво] как вы попали в Париж? Говорите по-польски.
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Byłam w obozie w Belsen w Niemczech do wyzwolenia, potem przyjechałam do Paryża, gdzie mam moją rodzinę, jedyną, która pozostała mi przy życiu. Ponieważ cała rodzina w Polsce zginęła.
David Boder: [In Russian] А где вы родились?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] W Warszawie.
David Boder: [In Russian] Вы родились в Варшаве и в каком году? Расскажите мне все, что случилось в таком времени, как немцы пришли сюда.
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Kiedy Niemcy przyszli do Warszawy, byłam w Warszawie jeszcze krótki czas do października czterdz...trzydziestego dziewiątego roku. W październiku przeszłam granicę sowiecko-niemiecką. Pojechałam do Lwowa. Tam mieszkałam półtorej roku blisko. Przeżyłam następnie wkroczenie...wybuch wojny sowiecko-niemieckiej. Nie zdążyłam już uciec ze Lwowa, ponieważ ewakuacja odbywała się bardzo szybko. Niemcy zaskoczyli mnie we Lwowie. Tam przeżyłam straszny pogrom, który miał miejsce w pierwszych dniach po wkroczeniu Niemców. Byłam we Lwowie do chwili utwo..., kiedy zaprojektowano utworzenie getta lwowskiego. Wtedy uciekłam ze Lwowa, nielegalnie, do Warszawy, ponieważ w Warszawie znajdowała się moja rodzina.
David Boder: [In Russian] Вы говорите, что был погром в Львове?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] We Lwowie był pogrom w kilka dni po wkroczeniu Niemców. Pogrom był dokonany właściwie nie przez samych Niemców, ale głównie przez Ukraińców...był to prawdziwie bestialski pogrom. Ukraińcy, Ukraińcy posługiwali się po prostu starym chłopskim systemem. Zabijali pałkami ludzi na śmierć, zabijali dzieci. Było wtedy bardzo wiele ofiar wśród Żydów.
David Boder: [In Russian] А немцы позволили им этот погром?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Niemcy...to było właściwie zaaranżowane przez Niemców, ale Niemcy woleli nie występować jawnie sami, tylko woleli, żeby to wyglądało jako spontaniczny odruch Ukraińców.
David Boder: [In Russian] А как вы вернулись в Варшаву?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Do Warszawy jechałam właściwie jako Aryjka, jako Polka, katoliczka, ale nie miałam żadnych dokumentów, przy czym jestem dosyć podobna do Żydówki, więc droga była bardzo niebezpieczna. W Krakowie na dworcu, to było o dwunastej w nocy, jakiś volksdeutsche, to znaczy volksdeutsche, szpicel niemiecki, tak, złapał mnie, pytał mnie o papiery. Nie miałam żadnych papierów. Znalazłam się na gestapo, ale przypadkiem, dzięki temu, że napotkałam tam na jakiegoś urzędnika kolejowego, Polaka...bardzo miłego i przyzwoitego człowieka, udało mi się wydostać. Odprowadził mnie na dworzec i pojechałam do Warszawy. W Warszawie już wtedy też nie wolno było Żydom poruszać się po tak zwanej aryjskiej stronie. Byli zamknięci w getcie. No, ale jakoś udało mi się przejść przez tą...przez dzielnicę polską i dostałam się do...dostałam się do getta przez jakąś dziurę w murze.
David Boder: [In Russian] А вы что, были уже замужем тогда?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Nie, nie byłam zamężna, nie.
David Boder: [In Russian] Нет, вы не были замужем. Конечно. А вот в Варшаве вы, значит, жили в гетто?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Tak, w Warszawie byłam w getcie od listopada czterdziestego pierwszego roku. Przez cały czas, aż do akcji wysiedleńczej.
David Boder: [In Russian] Расскажите мне, как была жизнь в варшавском гетто.
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Kiedy pierwszy raz znalazłam się w getcie, nie mogę opisać, jak wstrząsające wrażenie to wywołało na mnie. Od razu natknęłam się na takie widoki, z którymi już później się oswoiłam, ale o których nigdy nie mogę zapomnieć. Było wiele zburzonych domów w getcie. We wnękach murów siedziały dzieci żydowskie, blade, wychudzone, jak szkielety. Cieniutkie rączki, nóżki...i żebrały, cienkimi głosikami błagały o chleb. To było, pamiętam, pierwsze moje wrażenie. Drugie, równie wstrząsające, to było to, że wszyscy ludzie nosili opaski na ręku. To był jakiś dziwny świat ludzi z opaskami, ale ludzie ci zachowywali się jak normalni, porusza...
David Boder: [In Russian] Ну и как [неразборчиво] в гетто?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] W getcie byłam do chwili głównej akcji, to znaczy do lip...do dwudziestego drugiego lipca czterdziestego drugiego roku. Następnie przeżyłam tą całą akcję.
David Boder: [In Russian] Скажите мне, кто была с вами...был ваш отец, мать...где все эти были?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Nie, kiedy przyjechałam do Warszawy, ojciec mój już nie żył, a brat został zabity przez Niemców. Brat był bardzo wcześnie zabrany, ponieważ jeszcze, zdaje się w czterdziestym roku, Niemcy wzięli wielu inteligentów żydowskich jako zakładników i później ich rozstrzelali. Tak że byłam z matką i z siostrą.
David Boder: [In Russian] А где ваш отец был э-э-э...сперва э-э-э...как э-э-э...ваш отец...что...умер сперва или что?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Ojciec umarł w parę miesięcy po wybuchu wojny. Dokładnie nie wiem, bo byłam we Lwowie. Był bardzo słabym człowiekiem, przeżył bombardowanie Warszawy...I w ogóle był człowiekiem bardzo delikatnym i to wszystko, co widział, wpływało bardzo źle i pogorszyło to jego stan tak, że umarł w kilka miesięcy potem.
David Boder: [In Russian] А чем ваш отец занимался? С чего ваша семья жила до войны?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Ojciec był nauczycielem.
David Boder: [In Russian] Что?
David Boder: [In Russian] Это что? Учителем? И что учил?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Ojciec uczył języka polskiego, matematyki w szkołach powszechnych dla dzieci żydowskich.
David Boder: [In Russian] Ага. А сам он что окончил?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Ojciec mój uczył się na kursach zorganizowanych przez synagogę żydowską, dla Żydów, którzy chcieli się uczyć nauk świeckich, a potem zdawał egzamin nauczycielski u jakiegoś profesora polskiego. Otrzymał dyplom.
David Boder: [In Russian] И он умер, значит, после того, как немцы пришли в Польшу...
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Tak, umarł w parę miesięcy po tym.
David Boder: [In Russian] Он где умер? В Варшаве?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Tak umarł w Warszawie.
David Boder: [In Russian] Ну...а...в гетто он умер?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish]...jeszcze nie było getta.
David Boder: Jeszcze nie...
David Boder: [In Russian] Ну, значит, вы были в гетто и с кем вы были в гетто?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish]...z matką, z siostrą i z mężem siostry.
David Boder: [In Russian] И где вы жили там?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Myśmy żyli na Nowolipiu w domu...
David Boder: [In Russian] В доме?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish]...w naszym mieszkaniu, ponieważ to mieszka...Nowolipie należało do getta.
David Boder: [In Russian] А...значит, вы остались в своем доме, потому что [неразборчиво] сделали часть гетто. Хорошо.
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Tak.
David Boder: [In Russian] А этот дом принадлежал кому? [неразборчиво] Кто был хозяин дома?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] No był właściciel domu, przed wojną...
David Boder: [In Russian] Еврей или...
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] To był Żyd.
David Boder: [In Russian] Да. И вы платили за квартиру?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish]...z początku płaciliśmy, a potem...ja nie pamiętam.
David Boder: [In Russian] Хорошо. Когда вы, значит, вышли из гетто?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Potem zaczęła się akcja wysiedleńcza w dwudzie...dwudziestego drugiego lipca czterdziestego drugiego roku...wtedy ukrywaliśmy się trochę.
David Boder: [In Russian] В гетто?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] W samym getcie, jeżeli akcja była w...na jednej ulicy, tośmy przechodzili na drugą ulicę.
David Boder: [In Russian] А какая это акция была, скажите [неразборчиво]...
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Niemcy...ukazały się plakaty na murach, podpisane nawet przez gminę żydowską, że wszyscy Żydzi powinni zgłosić się do punktów przesiedleńczych...i będą przesiedleni na wschód. Każdy otrzyma trzy kilo chleba, kilo marmolady, dostar...dostarczy się wagonów i tymi wagonami Niemcy...Żydzi pojadą na wschód. Tam się ich osiedli w małych miasteczkach i tam będą pracować. Następnie było wymienione, że od akcji wysiedleńczej zwolnieni są ci Żydzi, którzy pracują w fabrykach niemieckich, następnie pracownicy gminy żydowskiej.
David Boder: [In Russian] И там это...были госпитали в гетто...были доктора?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Tak, były szpitale w getcie, byli lekarze, tylko że chorzy umierali po prostu z głodu. Było mało lekarstw. Nawet jak chorego udało się wyleczyć, to i tak nie miało się go czym odżywiać. Tak że była bardzo duża śmiertelność.
David Boder: [In Russian] И куда и где хоронили людей? А где хоронили [неразборчиво]?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Ludzi chowano na cmentarzu żydowskim.
David Boder: [In German/English] Was...was, war [unintelligible]...was that in Ghetto? The jüdische?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Cmentarz żydowski był trochę poza gettem, ale dostawało się przepustki i można było...nawet rodzina też mogła odprowadzić tych zmarłych...i można było ich chować na cmentarzu na getcie, na starym żydowskim cmentarzu. Jednych chowano we wspólnych grobach,...były ogromne wspólne groby,...była śmiertelność ostatnio około pięciu tysięcy ludzi miesięcznie, a tych, którzy mogli sobie pozwolić, chowano w grobach pojedynczych.
David Boder: [In Russian] Ну а потом как вы уехали из гетто?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Potem...po pierwszej akcji ja zostałam, dlatego że była...pozostało jeszcze około czterdziestu tysięcy Żydów po pierwszej akcji. Więc z tego część została na terenach kilku fabryk niemieckich, w których wyrabiano mundury dla wojska, buty, kożuchy i tak dalej. Więc udało mi się ukryć, ja tam pracowałam w takim ambulatorium fabrycznym. No i byłam w getcie do stycznia czterdziestego trzeciego roku. W styczniu wybuchła druga akcja...i w styczniu uciekłam na aryjską stronę,...właśnie w czasie tej drugiej akcji...też ucieczka była bardzo niebezpieczna, ale wyjechaliśmy jakimś autem fabrycznym, ja niby jako pracownica tej fabryki. Była [niezrozumiały], znaczy się taka brama w murze. Tam stali żandarmi niemieccy i kontrolowali każdego, kto wyjeżdżał z getta. No i akurat, jak to auto wyjeżdżało, przyjechał patrol SS-owski, który przeprowadzał akcje. Kazano wszystkim wysiąść z auta. Rewidowano. Ja byłam jedyną kobietą. Nawet wszyscy mężczyźni byli pewni, że mnie od razu zabiorą na Umschlagplatz, to był ten plac zborny, gdzie zbierano wszystkich Żydów, ale jakimś dziwnym przypadkiem pozwolono mi wsiąść do auta i wyjechaliśmy. Tam auto się zatrzymało, gdzieś na ulicy Puławskiej. Miałam tam znajomych, Aryjczyków. Wysiadłam z auta i w ten sposób wyszłam z getta.
David Boder: [In Russian] [неразборчиво] говорите дальше.
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] No, było mi bardzo trudno ukrywać się, ponieważ mam wygląd bardzo semicki. Ci Polacy, u których byłam, przyjęli mnie dobrze, ale musiałam szereg razy zmieniać mieszkanie. Ostatni raz zamieszkałam na Muranowskiej ulicy, akurat na wprost getta. No i w ten sposób widziałam akcję niemiecką w kwietniu czterdziestego trzeciego roku. Powstanie w getcie warszawskim,...ponieważ nasze okna...
David Boder: [In Russian] Вы были там, когда [неразборчиво]
Helena Neufeld: Я была, видела, я видела.
David Boder: Вы видели. Ну, расскажите про восстание.
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Więc okna nasze wychodziły akurat na róg ulicy Muranowskiej i Nalewek. W ten sposób mogliśmy obserwować cały plac Muranowski, część Nalewek i ulicę...zdaje się Miłą, która prowadziła właśnie do tego Umschlagplatzu, na którym zbierano wszystkich Żydów. Tak że widzieliśmy wszystkie pochody żydowskie, które Niemcy prowadzili na Umschlagplatz. Osiemnastego kwietnia nagle rano zaczęła się strzelanina. Nie wiedzieliśmy w ogóle, że [niezrozumiały]. Doszliśmy do okien. Widzieliśmy, że mur getta jest otoczony bardzo gęsto posterunkami, które...każdy posterunek składał się zwykle z jednego Niemca, jednego Ukraińca, jednego policjanta polskiego. Posterunki były ustawione co dziesięć, piętnaście kroków...i co pewien...nie pamiętam, czy każdy, czy co drugi posterunek miał karabin maszynowy. Wiedzieliśmy od razu, że szykuje się jakaś akcja w getcie, bo każda akcja była poprzedzona właśnie obsadzeniem całego muru. No i rozpoczęła się formalna bitwa. Bardzo zaciekła. Więc słyszeliśmy karabiny maszynowe. Następnie granaty. W pewnym momencie usłyszeliśmy znany...usłyszałam znany odgłos, ale nie wierzyłam oczom. To były tanki. Spojrzałam w Nalewki...i rzeczywiście z Nalewki powoli wyjeżdżały dwa tanki niemieckie. No to już znaczyło, że to jest koniec getta.
David Boder: [In Russian] Ну, расскажите, что потом случилось с вами, как долго вы были в Варшаве и как вы убрались из Варшавы.
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Potem ukrywałam się jeszcze jakiś czas, ale było mi bardzo trudno ukrywać się. Później Niemcy zabrali nas do...zabrali mnie do obozu. Do Belsen-Bergen. To było w lipcu czterdziestego trzeciego roku. W tym obozie byłam dwadzieścia miesięcy. Przeszło dwadzieścia miesięcy...do jakiegoś trzynastego kwietnia czterdziestego piątego roku. Wtedy zaczęto ewakuować obóz. Zbliżali się podobno Anglicy. Ewakuowano nas dziesiątego kwietnia. Dwa tygodnie byłam w pociągu do dwudziestego trzeciego kwietnia.
David Boder: [In Russian] Вас эвакуировали из Бельзен?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Tak...
David Boder: [In Russian] Кто?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Niemcy, Niemcy mieli zwyczaj, wszystkie obozy, do których zbliżali się Anglicy czy Amerykanie, ewakuować. O ile zdążyli. Tak więc Belsen też zaczęli ewakuować i mnie ewakuowali.
David Boder: [In Russian] В Бельзен знали, что вы еврейка?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Tak w Belsen byli...było bardzo wielu Żydów. Byli Żydzi polscy, Żydzi węgierscy, Żydzi rumuńscy, jugosłowiańscy, Żydzi holenderscy.
David Boder: [In Russian] Ага, э-э-э...как долго вы были в Бельзен?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Przeszło dwadzieścia miesięcy.
David Boder: [In Russian] Сколько?
Helena Neufeld: Больше чем двадцать.
David Boder: Двадцать месяцев. Расскажите про жизнь в Бельзен. Как вы жили в этом...блок ваш...и так далее.
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Więc...
David Boder: [In Russian] Вы работали в Бельзен?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Nie, myśmy nie pracowali.
David Boder: [In Russian] Нет. Значит, двадцать месяцев вы не работали. Сколько вас было человек в одном блоке?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Początkowo to była...myśmy byli trzymani oddzielnie...to byli Żydzi z Polski. Więc to była grupa przeszło dwa tysiące pięćset osób...początkowo. Następnie zaczęto w październiku...już po trzech miesiącach wysłano z naszej grupy przeszło tysiąc osób. Blisko dwa tysiące osób. Później dowiedzieliśmy się, że wysłano ich do Oświęcimia.
David Boder: [In Russian] Э-э-э...как вы спали там в этом бараке?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Z początku warunki jeszcze były trochę lepsze. Nie było tak ciasno. Więc każdy z nas miał swoją pryczę..., ale prycze były dwupiętrowe. Jedna była dolna, a druga była górna...i bardzo ciasno ustawione. Nie można się było obrócić. Te korytarzyki były tak ciasne...to nas bardzo męczyło. Przykrywaliśmy się kocami. Mieliśmy takie sienniki. Dostawaliśmy zupę, chleb, czasem trochę margaryny.
David Boder: [In Russian] А что делали целый день?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Nic...nic. Nasza grupa nie pracowała. Były grupy, które pracowały, inne nie pracowały.
David Boder: [In Russian] А вы знали эту женщину в Бельзен...как ее звали?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Irma...
David Boder: [In Russian] Ирма [неразборчиво]?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Nie, ja jej nie znałam, ale komendanta Kramera znałam.
David Boder: [In Russian] Вы знали Крамера?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Tak. Widziałam go parę razy. Z początku mieliśmy innego komendanta, Hassa, a potem zastąpił go Kramer.
David Boder: [In Russian] А вы были здоровы в Бельзен?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Nie...w Belsen...Przyjechałam do Belsen już chora,...bo byłam jeszcze dwa tygodnie w więzieniu, w Warszawie, na Pawiaku. No i poza tym byłam, przeżyłam bardzo dużo w czasie, kiedy się ukrywałam. Przyjechałam chora i potem,...wszyscy byli chorzy, dlatego żeśmy dostawali bardzo mało jeść tak, że wszyscy byli spuchnięci. Mieli nogi spuchnięte i twarze spuchnięte i wszyscy byli bardzo słabi. Początkowo jeszcze dostawaliśmy jeść. Potem coraz gorzej, coraz gorzej. Pierwszy rok jeszcze jako takośmy wytrzymali. Chociaż zimę spędziliśmy w kamiennych barakach. Było zimno. Dachy przeciekały. Woda się lała.
David Boder: [In Russian] Так...скажите, а если кто-нибудь заболевал, что делали тогда?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Było...między tymi więźniami był, byli lekarze. Oni leczyli chorych, a oprócz tego był taki duży szpital. Jak były jakieś poważniejsze wypadki, to meldowało się niemieckiemu lekarzowi,...no i tych chorych się zabierało do szpitala.
David Boder: [In Russian] Так...а потом, значит, вас эвакуировали из Бельзен куда?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Ten pociąg jechał tam i z powrotem, tam i z powrotem, dlatego że wszystkie drogi były przecięte i były bombardowane, stacje się paliły, tak że pociąg miał jechać do Theresienstadt, do Czech...
David Boder: [In German] Tschech—...
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish]...tak, ale bardzo niedaleko zajechał, dlatego że maszynista nie mógł prowadzić pociągu po tych bombardowanych drogach.
David Boder: [In Russian] [неразборчиво]
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Były naloty...Nie. Były naloty, bombardowania...
David Boder: [In Russian] Вы не доехали до Терезиенштадт...
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Nie, myśmy gdzieś byli...
David Boder: [In Russian]...И кто вас освободил?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Rosjanie.
David Boder: [In Russian] Русские?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Tak.
David Boder: [In Russian] Русские вас освободили? Расскажите, как случилось это.
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] [niezrozumiały]
David Boder: [In Russian] Вы были в поездах?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish]...myśmy byli w wagonach...w wagonie towarowym. Noc...nawet całą noc pociąg stał. Nawet było dosyć spokojnie. Z daleka było słychać strzały, ale nie było żadnego nalotu. Z samego rana, o szóstej może, ktoś przebiegł koło naszego wagonu i powiedział: „już są Rosjanie, już Niemcy uciekli”.
David Boder: [In Russian] Что они, русские, вам дали есть?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Tak, więc wszyscy wybiegli z wagonu i rzeczywiście byli dwaj sowieccy żołnierze na koniach. No i powiedzieli: „wyjdźcie już z wagonów. Każdy może iść na wieś. Tam znajdziecie...wejdźcie do mieszkań, tam...”.
David Boder: [In Russian] В каком городе это было?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish]...to było koło...[niezrozumiały], gdzieś koło Drezna. Małe miasteczko.
David Boder: [In Russian] Хорошо. [неразборчиво] ну, оттуда когда вас освободили...куда вы поехали?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish]...myśmy byli chorzy bardzo, więc...
David Boder: [In Russian] Ваша сестра была с вами?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Nie, nie było z mojej rodziny nikogo. Więc poszliśmy do najbliższej wioski niemieckiej. Tam weszliśmy do domu niemieckiego, wykąpaliśmy się, po pierwsze, i położyliśmy się do łóżek, i leżeliśmy w łóżkach.
David Boder: [In Russian] И оттуда куда вы поехали?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Leże...miesiąc czasu leżeliśmy tam, bo nie mieliśmy sił chodzić. Byliśmy bardzo słabi, a potem ja pojechałam do Paryża.
David Boder: [In Russian] Зачем вы в Париж поехали? У ва...
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Bo w Polsce nie miałam rodziny...wiedziałam przecież,...matka moja zginęła w czasie akcji jeszcze. Jej siostra, też wiedziałam, że zginęła. Tak że pojechałam do Paryża, gdzie mam rodzinę.
David Boder: [In Russian] У вас есть родственники в Париже?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Mam kuzynki dwie.
David Boder: [In Russian] У вас есть две кузины тут, в Париже.
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Tak, tak.
David Boder: [In Russian] Ну, а что вы теперь собирали...А где вы вышли замуж?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Za mąż ja wyszłam w getcie.
David Boder: [In Russian] О! Вы вышли в гетто?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Tak.
David Boder: [In Russian] И что с мужем вашим [неразборчиво].
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Mąż też był w obozie.
David Boder: [In Russian] Куда?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish]...też był...w Belsen był.
David Boder: [In Russian] Вас послали, мужчин и женщин...А немцы знали, что это был ваш муж?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Tak, tak, oni znali, że to mój mąż.
David Boder: [In Russian] И э-э-э...потом с вами все время ехали, доехали до Бельзен и остались [неразборчиво].
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] W Belsen, tam byliśmy oddzielnie, a potem znów byliśmy razem, a potem nas ewakuowali.
David Boder: [In Russian] И были вместе, когда русские пришли...вы были вместе?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Wszyscy, tak.
David Boder: [In Russian] Вы были вместе. И тогда вы решили оба поехать в Париж?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Tak.
David Boder: [In Russian] Как вы поехали, у вас были деньги?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Nie, myśmy nie mieli wcale pieniędzy i jechaliśmy bez pieniędzy cały czas, autami wojskowymi, a potem pociągami dla repatriantów.
David Boder: [In Russian] Вас впустили во Францию или [неразборчиво]?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish]...wpuścili. Ja mówię trochę po francusku i ja mam rodzinę...
David Boder: [In Russian] Где вы учились по-французски?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] W szkole jeszcze nauczyłam się, ja bardzo lubiłam francuski.
David Boder: [In Russian] Вы что, ходили в гимназию в Варшаве?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Tak.
David Boder: [In Russian] Да. А ваш муж где учился?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Też w Warszawie.
David Boder: [In Russian] А откуда он английский знает?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] On uczył się angielskiego.
David Boder: [In Russian] Ага. А что ваш муж делает в Париже?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] No...z początku myśmy nic nie robili, myśmy się źle czuli. Teraz on pracował trochę jako tłumacz.
David Boder: [In Russian] А что вы собираетесь делать?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Nie wiemy jeszcze, to bardzo ciężka decyzja. Mam przyjaciół w Ameryce, którzy bardzo chcą, żebym tam pojechała. Rodziny nie mam gdzie indziej. Może zostanę w Paryżu. Nie wiadomo.
David Boder: [In Russian] Ага. У вас есть родственники в Америке?
Helena Neufeld: Нет. Подруги.
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Przyjaciół mam w Ameryce. [niezrozumiały]
David Boder: [In Russian] Нет родственников. А ваш муж чем занимается? Что он работает?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] On pracował jako tłumacz.
David Boder: [In Russian] [неразборчиво]
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Z Amerykanami.
David Boder: [In Russian] С американскими?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Tutaj, w amerykańskich instytucjach, bo zna angielski.
David Boder: [In Russian] Что он делает?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Ja nie wiem nawet.
David Boder: [In Russian] И для американского правительства, и для еврейских организаций.
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Nie, nie, to nie to...nie wiem...dla polskich czy dla amerykańskich.
David Boder: [In Russian] Да. Он работает для них. И он придет домой в десять часов?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Tak, on przyjdzie.
David Boder: [In Russian] Он придет. Скажите, [неразборчиво] были какие-нибудь песни, которые эти пленные пели?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] My?
David Boder: [In Russian] Да.
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish]...pieśni mało...
David Boder: [In Russian] [неразборчиво]
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Tak, były...
David Boder: [In Russian] [неразборчиво] есть новые песни, которые делали в этом лагере?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Nie, nie, nie...nie.
David Boder: [In Russian] Вы не знаете...
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Nie, nie...u nas owszem pisano wiersze.
David Boder: [In Russian] Что?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Wiersze.
Helena Neufeld: [In Russian] Стихи.
David Boder: Писали...и тоже стихи писали? Знаете какие-нибудь [неразборчиво]?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Nie, ja nie pisałam, może mąż będzie pamiętał coś.
David Boder: [In Russian] Вы знаете какие-нибудь [неразборчиво]?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Nie.
David Boder: [In Russian] Не знаете...
David Boder: [In English] Well, this concludes the record of Ms. Helena Neufeld. Eh...she...eh...insists on making her record in Polish, she is apparently conscious about her language, and she is staying with her hus..., she married her husband in the Ghetto in Warsaw, and it so happened that through all the deportations they were together. August the 3rd, 1946. Paris the home [unintelligible] Jews. After concluding the record of so many, as often happens, you get some new data. On the question of [unintelligible] she tells me that she is a dentist graduated from Warsaw.
David Boder: [In German] Wann haben Sie dentistry studiert?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] [niezrozumiały]
David Boder: [In Russian] [неразборчиво]?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Studiowałam od trzydziestego pierwszego do końca trzydziestego piątego roku...tysiąc dziewięćset trzydziestego pierwszego do końca tysiąc dziewięćset trzydziestego piątego roku.
David Boder: [In Russian] Так сколько же вам лет?
Helena Neufeld: Тридцать три.
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Trzydzieści trzy.
David Boder: [In Russian] Вы что, поступили в зубоврачебную школу в Варшаве? Когда? Сразу после гимназии?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] Nie, właściwie nie chciałam [niezrozumiały] romanistykę. Chciałam wyjechać za granicę do Francji, ale rodzice bardzo pragnęli, żebym wstąpiła na dentystykę, więc...
David Boder: [In Russian] Что вы теперь работаете тут? У дантиста или как, сами работаете?
Helena Neufeld: [In Polish] [niezrozumiały]